صباح العربيه اليوم ينفرد بالاعلان ما قبل
الرسمي لاطلاق اذاعه العربيه اذا نبدا
صباح اليوم بالاستعداد مع شبكه العربيه
الاخباريه لتدشين واطلاق اذاعه العربيه اف
ام في بثا يبدا صلاه غدا الاثنين
الانطلاقه ستكون من العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض وستقدم الاذاعه خدمه الاخباريه
لتغطيه اهم الاحداث العربيه والعالميه
وستتناول اذاعه العربيه اهم الاخبار
السياسيه والاقتصاديه والرياضيه وغيرها
والبرامج الصباحي والاذاعي الموازي لوقت
عرض برنامج صباح العربيه سيقدم كل ما هو
جديد في عالم التقنيه والصحه والرياضه
والاقتصاد
الاقرب الي الاقرب اليك العربيه
في الرياض على الموجه
103.5
وفي الدمام 88.9
وفي جده
106.6 وعلى تطبيق العربيه على الاجهزه
الذكيه وموقع العربيه
العربيه.
اينما تكونون اينما تكونون
العربيه اف ام دائما معكم
العربيه دائما معكم
على كل من رياضيات ضم الينا رندا الشيخ
رئيس فريق عمل العربيه اف ام اهلا بك يا
رندا مبروك انطلاق غدا ان شاء الله لاذاعه
العربيه اف ام اذا الاذاعه العربيه عبر
اثير اف ام ستنطلق من الرياض غدا ما الذي
تعدون المستمعين
اهلا بك
صباح الخير للمشاهدين طبعا احنا العمل على
قدم وساق في فريق اذاعه العربيه اف ام
لتقديم كل جديد حتكون عندنا خدمه نوعيه
اخباريه مختلفه
الاذاعه كما تعلمون تختلف تماما عن
التلفزيون لكونها تصل الى شريحه اكبر من
المتلقين حيكون عندنا برامج منوعه حيكون
عندنا برامج اخباريه تحليل الخبر يعني
اذاعه العربيه امتداد لشبكه العربيه
الاخباريه رنده كمان اسمحي لي انا كمان
ابارك لكم بهذه الانطلاقه والاذاعه هي
الاساس دائما يعني في الاعلام العربي
والغربي دائما بدا من الاذاعات لكن راندا
دائما اليوم السؤال بقولوا لماذا الان
لماذا الان اذاعه العربيه هل السوق فعلا
يحتاج اذاعه لكي تنافس الموجود
شبكه العربيه الاخباريه كما تعلمين زميلتي
نادين دائما سباقه فانها تتواجد على كل
المنصات
مشروع اذاعه العربيه اف ام المفروض يكون
من زمان ولكن الفرصه الان متاحه لتقديم
هذا الاذاعه بالامكانيات الموجوده
المتطوره الذكاء الاصطناعي يعني حنستخدم
كل الامكانيات المتواجده الان تقنيا وفنيا
العربيه سبقت في تقديم اللي هي اكثر منصه
اكثر متواجده على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لماذا لا يكون لها موجه على الاف ام تصل
الى شريحه اكبر يعني زي ما تعرفي الاذاعه
تصل الى مناطق نائيه لا يصل فيها
التلفزيون وممكن الناس ما يكون عندهم اصلا
جوالات
فاعتقد انها خطوه مهمه
لفتني انه اضافه للبرامج المتنوعه لاذاعه
العربيه ستكون هناك تغطيه اخباريه يعني
نشرات نواجز اخباريه وكذلك رست ومواكبه
لكل العواجل حديث نا اكثر عن الجانب
الاخباري
هذا اللي موجود الحين عندنا نشره اخباريه
صباحيه من السابعه صباحا اليها صباح
العربيه اف ام وعندنا نشره الظهير الساعه
2 وعندنا برنامج مساء ان شاء الله من
الثامنه وحتى العاشره انا بس خليني كمان
اوضح هيك لنفسي وللمشاهدين انتم عم تقولوا
في برنامج صباحي موازي على اذاعه العربيه
يعني احنا في صباح العربيه على الشاشه
وبرنامج مختلف تماما على اذاعه العربيه
صحيح طيب وماذا ستعملون لكي تنافسون
نتنافس يا رنده
لسه كنت حقول احنا بنحاول انه نكون ندخل
في المنافسه طبعا انتم عندكم الخبره اكبر
مننا ولكن احنا عندنا فريق كمان جاهز انه
يدخل السباق مع صباح العربي احنا قلنا
التحدي يا رندا
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله اكيد
كلنا شبكه واحده اكيد بالتاكيد يعني
احنا طبعا والف الف مبروك وتحيه كمان
للزملاء من البرنامج الموازي لصباح
العربيه رندا الشيخ رئيسه فريق عمل
العربيه فمن شكرا جزيلا لك كل التوفيق
شكرا